what I think runs young people pride
yeah let me explain I'm trying to put
myself in your nice shoes right now and
I'm saying you know there's a part of
you it's like look I don't want it to
just be homies that he's going to get me
I'm gonna go get mine do my thing I
actually think that's a stunning
vulnerability that a lot of people get
caught on I think you should recruit a
Tennessee and hard I or and I don't know
your rolodex or anybody else you played
with or your best friend the league or
who the [ __ ] knows right I I really
think that's a really interesting thing
for you to debate you know do you know I
spent my hope do you know even when this
is gonna blow your mind what I'm about
to say maybe AJ is the only one that
really knows this you know even as you
were about to say what you were about to
say about my background I didn't like it
I know how great I am and I wish my
story was zero to 60 not three to six
day because then people can be like well
he had this like I know what I am and it
sucks I used to cry is to call my mother
and cry and be like nobody's ever gonna
give me credit you know this like this
was the biggest fear of my life when I
knew I was special at 18 like I'm gonna
be it I was like like it's and so what
ends up happening is if you're good
enough you're good enough I'm sure AJ
had a deal with it with vaynermedia
right his brother was like what did he
like you know so I think we I think
pride I think AJ is very successful life
because he knew how to calibrate the the
good Nevada so I think when you start
something don't you made a bunch of
people who if they don't know anything
about you you're 23 this and that you're
not gonna prove it to that man
impossible no matter how smart you are
here's the war room with see you know
c-suite executives at every fortune 500
but when you're 23 walked into a room
then I get the [ __ ] out of here well so
I stay on moving on like I don't even
start to try to convince anybody i
actually prefer them not to believe and
then show them later because you
wouldn't i'm over harder so what I would
do if you were like my son or brother be
like listen here's what you do let's
figure out you know when a man says
brothers like whatever he can put you on
to great whatever to felt like I don't
know but like whenever you start with
advantages with your high school coach
who taught this kit like take up all
those things because I'll tell you some
of the things that I've done not
in my career where I had too much ego
and pride and didn't want to take the
easy thing just stupid at the end of the
day the net score is the net score so I
would give that thought